make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so back in 2014 one of the first videos
I did explaining comic book characters
was carnage and it was about 7 minutes
and 42 seconds long and it was a single
image and it was nothing like the
explained videos that we did later on so
we're gonna change that we are gonna do
carnage explained and we're gonna do it
the comics explained way so because of
that uh when it came to it when it came
to carnage he originally made his
appearance in Marvel Comics back in
amazing spider-man issue number 361 now
this was a match 92 but one thing to
bear in mind is that cletus kasady first
appeared back in issue number 344 and
the basis behind this the intention
behind this with David McLean II at
least according to an interview he did
with sci-fi wire in 2018 was that he
looked at the character of carnage and
what he wanted to do was take the Venom
symbiote and bounce it from one person
to another right like the notion of
carnage didn't really exist michaleen II
wanted to take the venom Samiha away
from Eddie Brock and he wanted to simply
give the Venom symbiote to various
characters they saw in whatever story
was that he wanted to tell the problem
with this is that while Eddie Brock was
truly a villain why I guess he was a
villain more or less in the spider-man
comics he was complex and if there was
any one thing that fans loved when it
comes to come up with characters it's
characters who were complex who were
sometimes good guys who were sometimes
bad guys who were thrust into scenarios
they don't want to be and different
things like that but more so than that
we had never really seen an instance
where spider-man faced off against a
villain who had an inherent ability to
block his spider sense right it was kind
of the core part of spider-man's mythos
and to be able to get around that was a
pretty huge thing and so with those two
concepts combined not to mention the
history between Eddie Brock and Peter
Parker Eddie was a supremely popular
character in the late 80s in the early
90s the result of this was that when
Nicolini approached the Marvel brass and
said hey look here's the plan here's
what I want to do Marvel said absolutely
not they said no now there were a few
reasons for this not in you know to kind
of leaving out what we talked about a
second ago another big thing behind it
was because Marlowe was publishing
around 100 comics a month at that point
in time because they were so hugely
popular in terms of the stories that
were being made and the kind of tales
are being released hence the reason why
I say 99 these comics of Marvel was
insane but it was also the idea that
there really seemed to be no end to the
popularity of spider-man and the various
spider-man characters that were going on
and so the result was that mickalene Ian
Eric Larsen had to kind of go back to
the drawing board and find a way to
create a new symbiote that could
basically tie in to the spider-man
mythos and still keep Eddie Brock intact
and so enter a
lazy spider-man number 344 now the way
this worked out kind of going in the
chronological order of the publications
you somebody just had Eddie Brock who
was sharing a cell with Cletus Kasady
for like 11 murders he committed or
something on those lines regardless of
the scenario Cletus did not like Eddie
Brock and so he actually intended to
take him out while he was sharpening a
shiv or at least by by creating a shift
the result was that during this process
uh Eddie Brock was broken out by the
Venom symbiote which left behind a
portion of itself that was technically
its offspring which in turn bonded
itself to Cletus Kasady the issue with
this and in really one of the big things
at mickalene II and Eric Larsen had to
contend with was how to introduce a
villain that could basically stand out
and stand the test of time right because
if any Brock was a vet was a villain
unto himself by way of the Venom
symbiote and the question was how do you
make carnage a character that's unique
and interesting they could be a threat
to both venom and spider-man and so they
made this small little change that we
had never really seen before and that
was the carnage symbiote bonding to
Cletus Kasady through the bloodstream
when it came to venom that was just
essentially like a symbiotic suit that
covered Eddie Brock and that was really
it and gave him enhanced abilities
different things like that but actually
have the carnage symbiote bond itself -
Cletus on the cellular level basically
allowed Marvel to kind of come along and
say well this is what happens when to
send me a bond with you on this level
you become a lot more powerful than you
normally would if it just bonded with
your suit and that's exactly what
happened and so between issues 344 going
into issue number 360 one and then 361
going forward for the most part in
between those two college you kind of
saw these bits and pieces here and there
you didn't really see a whole lot
instead it wasn't really until 360 one
proper that you basically got this
full-on introduction and this idea of
what it was that the carnage simia was
fully uh fully capable of now when it
came to spider-man unlimited number one
when it came to amazing spider-man 361
to 363 this involved Peter Parker
invoking like the Fantastic Four and
having to team up with venom in order to
take out Cletus Kasady now the original
story was really more of a taste for
what kind of character we could expect
when it came to this new concept and
during this forum post that was made
back in 2007 you had Eric Larsen I think
it was back on the old image comics
forum who basically said that like the
basis behind Cletus was to kind of
answer the question what if the Joker
became venom right and so that was that
was the whole concept behind it and so
with this original conflict that drove
Peter Parker to sort of grab some
information from the Fantastic Four and
then ultimately team-up with venom
carnage came about as this guy who would
just kill indiscriminately and then just
write carnage
just on like amazon blood on walls and
different things like that it was
something that we hadn't really seen
before now in terms of the physical look
in terms of like the the actual red red
and black looking suit this was just
basically modeled in the concept of
blood and the reason for this was
because at least according to David
Nicolini the idea was that at the time
in Marvel and really in the world as a
whole you had a few things going on in
the world you had like the AIDS epidemic
right the idea that like blood was a
scary theme because blood is how you get
sick as I end up contracting diseases
and it kills you and so on and so there
was very much that public fear in
relation like dealing with dealing with
things were being exposed to blood the
second part was that in Marvel Marvel
already had their own kind of
introduction of an AIDS type epidemic in
the form of the legacy virus but the
issue with this was of the legacy virus
was largely confined to the mutant
population so the idea was to grab that
concept and throw it into the spider-man
spider-man landscape and see where they
went from there and so kind of building
on that that's the reason why venom
looks the way he does because one is
basically like the sisimiut kind of
manifest from the bloodstream hence the
reason why it's red and two because it's
Hye's into that whole blood fear and so
on but with this character being
introduced it was it was indiscriminate
murder it was mayhem it was panic it was
something that we hadn't really seen
we'd never really seen a villain
introduced in such a way to where there
was no real moral compass the only
exception to that was probably
Sabretooth by us out of that most all
villains had a moral compass to a degree
or at least an overarching goal they
were trying to achieve whether it be the
acquisition of wealth or power or
what-have-you
with carnage it was just chaos and
pandemonium because he was a nihilist so
you believe that life was meaningless
and the only way to really be free is to
do whatever you want and to free people
quote/unquote by basically killing them
and so at the end of this introduction
of his character ultimately he was
defeated by the combined efforts of
spider-man and venom now the popularity
of this story cannot be overstated
because it was insanely huge when it
wouldn't happen it was big it was the
first time we'd seen a tried and true
team-up between spider-man and venom
arguably two of the most popular
characters Marvel had going at the time
outside of the x-men and then in turn
teaming up against Seville and the likes
of which we had almost never really seen
before and so Marvel immediately set to
work on creating kind of a follow-up to
it and this of course came in the form
of the story that most of you guys have
heard of maximum carnage
now maximum carnage was a crossover
between the amazing spider-man comics
spectacular spider-man and spider-man
unlimited and this was huge not only
because it just involved the return of
carnage but also because I saw him
teaming up with shriek who had the
ability to basically like emit they
this kind of scream that would drive
people to insanity and start attacking
each other demo Goblin carry on
doppelganger who of course was a
multi-armed doppelganger or spider-man
hence the name but the idea behind this
was to essentially have Carnage's
unleash absolute havoc on the city of
New York and that's basically what
happened using that using the abilities
of shriek these various schemes and so
on and so forth
New York descended into absolute madness
now ultimately of course it was all
stopped by the combination of spider-man
the various superheroes and and so on
and so forth but what this did is it set
the stage and really like established in
the minds of Marvel Comics fans that
carnage was here to stay the ironic
thing about this is that depending on
who you talk to some people will say
this is where carnage peaked and many
just never really recovered after that
that he never really achieved that that
same level of popularity and there are a
couple reasons to make that argument the
first is because of the fact that at
that point in time the introducing again
I character in that regard was something
that we hadn't really seen before but
the second was because Marvel could get
away with a lot more things in the 1990s
and they could now I think people are a
lot more sensitive to things now as a
result is that having a character who
just sort of goes through and
indiscriminately murders people is
something that most people would would
kind of vocalize and be upset about
most likely having never read it but
nonetheless you know it's it's it's one
of these cool concepts because it gave
us a film that we weren't really used to
seeing but again you know even back then
stories were high octane they were fast
paced there were all kinds of things
that were going on in terms of basically
crafting like these super energetic and
wild and like violent stories in a lot
of ways but again the arrival of carnage
here almost kind of came at the worst
possible time because shortly after this
happened within three years after the
introduction of carnage suddenly Marvel
went to the comic buffs in the 1990s and
those you guys who weren't aware of that
it was basically a result where the the
comic book fan base almost destroyed the
comic book industry by just going
through and just buying tons of variants
and different things like that again
we've talked about before distributors
were kind of extortion really specify
how many copies of a comic an individual
person was buying did we simply tell
Marvel and DC here's how many of these
comics are being sold and what I did is
it gave off the impression that there
was a huge amount of popularity in
comics far more popularity than that
then people really thought there was and
so the result was that the more comics
that were being made of course the less
value those comics Hat's so when you
went out and you bought the death of
Superman number one and you bought like
the first issue of national carnage
where it all kicks off Marvel would
print out like a single issue and they
will print out
and if there were only like 20 of them
or a hundred or 200 those of those
comics they'd be worth a lot but there
were thousands and thousands and
thousands hundreds of thousands of those
comics going out which meant they were
worth virtually nothing and so people
just stopped buying them which meant
that comics sales started to collapse
and Marvel almost completely went
bankrupt and so because this whole this
whole situation kind of going belly-up
what this meant was that for the
character of carnage
Marvel didn't really have a whole lot of
time to basically start crafting a ton
of amazing stories about him instead we
got stories where Cletus Kasady lost the
Venom symbiote and then painted himself
red and went on the killing spree
different things like that but it was
just small little moments there wasn't
anything nearly as huge this really
began to change though once we got into
around 2004 to 2006 and we got the raft
storyline now the raft storyline was
crafted by Brian Michael Bendis and it
was the first arc of New Avengers now
kind of a little bit of explanation here
right people who are who aren't really
familiar with that for those are guys
who are great with before second New
Avengers was basically Marvel's way of
doing exactly what it sounds like
creating a new level of Avengers so when
Marvel had their common bus in the 1990s
Marvel basically resorted to publishing
comics in as cheap of a form as they
possibly could especially when it came
to characters who just weren't selling
well the result was that by the time the
late 1990s came around Marvel actually
contracted a lot of their work out to
event publications now event
publications was a company owned by
Jimmy Paul miyagi and Joe Quesada and
these were two guys who made their bones
by basically taking what were considered
to be the unsettles right so black
panther at that point in time the
punisher daredevil characters who just
couldn't really hold comics on their own
and event publications created those
stories and they wrote those things now
because of the fact that event in and
palmy ah t & casado Hearst had such a
huge hand in basically keeping Marvel
afloat and because a lot of the
decisions in terms of editorial work
that was being done by Marvel was being
was being made by Quezada even though he
didn't really work within the company
basically meant that by the time the
early 2000s came around and like Ike
Perlmutter and those guys a toy biz and
essentially become financial backers for
Marvel Comics and they can kind of get
back to business as usual Joe Quesada
was brought on as editor-in-chief and so
Joker saw his idea was let's just rework
everything right like what we've been
doing for the last 10 years is basically
what led to the near collapse of our
company right like printing 100 comics a
month and different things like that
we're gonna scale down and we're
basically gonna go back to the way
things used to be and so right wrong or
why's a lot of decisions were made by
casada in company that resulted in some
huge changes so like Peter Parker was no
longer married to Mary Jane Watson that
went away The Avengers were completely
disassembled 98% of the mutant
population lost their powers during and
after the events of house of M sweeping
changes made to the landscape but for
the character of our guests for the cost
of the Avengers again they were
basically broken down the Avengers
essentially lost all their financing
when Stark Industries almost went under
during House of M where at least lost a
huge amount of his profits during
Avengers disassembled and that in turn
led to the reformation of the New
Avengers and the way this came out again
with the raft storyline actually set the
seeds for Secret Invasion but
essentially all that happened at least
and with regards to carnage here is that
this story went into the character of
Elektra contract contracting the villain
electro to take down power to the raft
this giant prison for super-powered
beings and this led into a huge escape
now ultimately carnage made his escape
as well but was ultimately caught up to
by the century who'd been rolled over
into Marvel during this story he grabbed
carnage flew into space ripped him in
half and there was no indication carnage
was ever going to return following that
like things and New Avengers it just
kind of went forward as usual and that
was it right you get the second volume
who is a century and so on and so forth
this is actually followed up with what
was essentially a miniseries written by
Zeb wells a five-issue miniseries simply
called like carnage now this basically
detailed the aftermath to that and so
what this did is it established that
there were a handful of things going on
but there was a guy named Michael Hall
uh who had basically stumbled across the
remains of carnage kind of floating out
there in space right it's kind of left
there by the century on and then grabbed
it and then brought it back down to
earth and what he started doing was
using the carnage symbiote as a means to
basically create a product that can be
used to interface with the brain right
so he talked about making things like
prosthetics and then saying like this
prosthetic can essentially interact
directly with the brain and allow the
prosthetic arm or leg or whatever you
have to move in a more organic way than
would normally be achievable now
ultimately this drew the attention of
Tony Stark which in turn drew the
attention of spider-man and with the two
of them teaming up we ended up seeing
like the return of shriek and a few
other characters but we ended up
learning that the carnage symbiote was
trying to find a way back to its host
Cletus Kasady but the question was if
Cletus was dead after the events of the
wrath then what happened to him and
that's one when it was explained to us
that what the Simeon had done was
basically keep him alive as best it
could until he was essentially rescued
happened just in the nick of time but
because of the fact that Cletus Kasady
was kind of kept as a prisoner that when
the carnage symbiote broke out and REE
bonded itself to Cletus Kasady that it
was the official return of carnage going
into the new Marvel era but because of
this because Cletus Kasady was now back
on the stage and could his Cassidy now
had the Venom symbiote again the
question became what are people who
what's Marvel going to do after that
that's why I say some people look at
that and kind of say this is where he
peaked because following that we got a
few stories that came out it we got
carnage USA we're basically carnage
spread the Venom symbiote like across
the country we got the minimum carnage
storyline which saw Cletus traveling to
the Microverse eventually getting into a
conflict with Scarlet Spider and Anne
venom only to be stung by scholars
spider and put into a catatonic state we
saw the superior carnage storyline which
took place at the same time as superior
spider-man and basically led to Cletus
Kasady effectively being rebounded with
the carnage symbiote and fixing his
brain but then turning around and
becoming kind of like a model prisoner
of sorts you got the Deadpool vs.
carnage storyline which we need to do we
haven't actually done that yet but you
kind of got to use these carnage
miniseries more or less these small
little nooks and crannies that popped up
here here and there but what seemed to
be the case at least from what we saw
coming out of Marvel was that during
this point in time there really seemed
to be no indication that we were gonna
go back to the days of yesteryear the
mid-1990s when it was just carnage
indiscriminately murdering people and
writing carnage and blood on the walls
and indeed for the most part it didn't
we really wouldn't go back to that point
for quite some time at least really now
up until we are at least until we got to
the event of the dark hold but
especially now going into absolute
carnage but one of the better shifts of
the character one of the more
interesting shifts of the character came
by way of the axis event now axis was an
event that Marvel released back you
really like a few years ago heroes
became villains villains became heroes
and it was it was interesting for what
it was because it came out of red
onslaught where the Red Skull had
basically stole her mind of Charles
Xavier and was kind of you know kind of
amass like this new onslaught form it
was okay it was really more the tie-ins
that made the story interesting as
opposed to the main event itself but
this was a way to kind of turn carnage
into a good guy and sent him into a
phase of being a hero and one of the
reasons why this worked so well is
because as it was written by Rick Spears
the the carnage is high-end access gave
us a kind of depiction of the character
that we didn't see carnage was well
known as being a murderer he is well
known as being crazy it would be like if
the Joker became a good guy became like
a hero and it was awesome it was an
amazing story to see the issue with this
is that again axis was designed to
basically invert
for a temporary amount of time and then
to kind of see what's stuck and run with
it and so following axis where
characters like Iron Man stayed bad guys
basically became like the disappear
Ironman carnage went back to being a
villain again now during his time as a
hero he actually befriended Sam
Alexander and at the time sound
Alexander being the new Nova kind of
taking over the role for Richard Ryder
was hugely popular among young readers
and so Marvel really kind of looked at
that as a means to kind of follow the
Stanley Jack Kirby form and function of
the world the Fantastic Four played
albeit on a smaller scale and what I
mean by that is back in the 1960s the
1970s if Stan Lee and Jack Kirby wanted
to introduce a character or team and
basically kind of give them exposure to
a readership to a huge amount of
readership they would throw them in the
Fantastic Four it was kind of the the
premier team of Marvel or they would
team them off with spider-man or
something along those lines some huge
title they would get him exposures they
wouldn't normally see at the time
because Sam Alexander was so popular
kind of having him become sort of a hero
and friend to Sam during the events of
of axis and even kind of mentor him to a
degree only to have him turn back into a
bad guy and throw him back into Sam
Alexander stories was really Marvel's
attempt to kind of write giant purple
letters and saying carnage is back to
being a bad guy again carnage is back to
being a villain again and it was kind of
a good little reprieve for a little
while but ultimately it didn't really
seem to stick I mean the notion of him
being a villain was kind of the tried
and true form for him but people were
kind of looking for something a little
different and they were looking for
something a little more fresh and so
what Marvel did following that is going
into the really like the next major
story arc II had and his next volume was
basically dealing with the events of the
Darkhold and the character of C'thun now
a little bit of a explanation here in
Marvel Comics because I know the
Darkhold it's been talked about before
at least on this channel but we haven't
really gone super in-depth into it the
dark hold was a book it was created by
the the entity cathode now we talked
about him in our video about Scarlet
Witch and how powerful she could really
be if she tapped into all that all that
all those abilities at least if the MCU
decided to roll that concept into her
character from the comics but to kind of
keep this this short and simple cthe own
is basically in an ancient demon the
dark hold was a book that he wrote to
kind of inscribe the various dark magics
he'd been dealing in during his time on
earth before he was banished to a
different dimension and it's kind of his
link to earth right I mean those in
those individuals who possess the dark
hold and decide to summon cthe own can
bring him to earth for the purpose of
like destroying it and that's exactly
what cletus kasady did when the time
came
he ended up returning back his is
carnage you know yet again kind of
making his return you know for the
umpteenth time his idea was to kind of
magically amplify his power using the
dark hold and the power of C'thun but
where he attempted to kind of pull this
feat off he was ultimately met by the
intervention of a woman named Jubilee Oh
at least I think that's how you
pronounce your name but it was Jubilee
l-- who basically took the the toxin
symbiote from eddie brock as well as the
raised symbiote from a woman named dixon
who had actually been created by bio
carnage himself and then used all those
powers in addition to amplifying herself
with magical energy to actually banish
cthe own but for the most part Connors
was kind of defeated at the end of all
that but that's kind of the nature of
the character that's the nature of karna
that's why I say for a lot of people
they say he peaked during maximum
carnage that that particular story was
the best as character ever was and he
hasn't really been that good sense and
relation to the way is cured or existed
right I mean he was introduced you got
him versus spider-man you got I guess
him and spider-man and venom and then he
got maximum carnage and then it was he
was defeated he was locked up he escaped
he was defeated he was locked up he
escaped and defeated and locked up and
escaped and that's kind of the nature of
his care that's really what he's been
for the loss really I would say probably
the last 20 years or so you know for for
what Marvel's been doing with him in
terms of how he's function and so on
just kind of there and then something
happens and then he escapes or something
along those lines
not a whole lot doing now for those of
you guys who were getting into absolute
carnage who were wanting to kind of know
where to start this really comes by way
of the poison invasion now the poison
invasion is really kind of an offshoot
or kind of a continuation of the venom
eyes storyline right like this idea that
there are beings out there called
poisons who essentially bond themselves
to individuals take them over and then
keep all their powers and abilities
albeit they just kind of walk around as
being controlled by poisons but there is
a poison queen who of course controls
them all and there came a point when the
venom eyes storyline continued on the
poison event happened and it led to all
these various heroes and villains who
were controlled by the poisons on
infiltrating and kind of pouring into
the main Marvel Universe and when that
whole thing popped off it ultimately
came down to like really like a handful
of heroes facing off against the poison
Queen but it led to carnage basically
becoming the poison version of himself
and then in turn facing off against
venom and spider-man and this actually
led to him almost killing both but then
being shot out of an airlock and then
just kind of left there at the end of
the poison event he was believed to have
been dead or at least it seemed like he
was going to be dead and we didn't
really know what happened to him with
absolute carnage and really like the
things like a web of venom unleash
and like carnage born and things like
that well those kind of stories really
carnage born kind of details the origin
of carnage himself like the the
Unleashed storyline the kind of little
tie-ins and little you know backup
features that we see at the end of like
Donnie Cates venom run or designed to
build up to that and so for reasons that
I don't think have been wholly explained
yet that Cletus Kasady basically is
returned and he's leading his whole
thing with like the the Grendel symbiote
really like one of the original
symbiotes on earth kind of this
wholesale change to the venom venom
mythos that Donnie Cates has been
working on but that's really kind of the
place to start if you want to get into
absolute carnage but in reality I would
just kind of pick up with it and go like
I would just grab absolute carnage and
just kind of go forward and read it I'm
pretty sure it'll be standalone I think
it'll be written in such a way where you
don't really know need to know a whole
lot about Cletus Kasady and if you do I
think most all of it will be explained
by Donnie Cates and the first couple
issues of the story if not you know over
the course of the entire story but again
you know carnage is one of those
characters where he was exceedingly
popular in the 1990s the comic bucks
happened and Marvel never really knew to
do with him after that way because the
nature of comics as they were being told
at the time and the progression of that
style of storytelling kind of moved away
from the type of storytelling that
favored a character like carnage so
again it's interesting when it when it
comes to him but you know some people
say you peaked in the 90s and kind of
part of that crowd to a degree but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained to make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the robb core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]